so does that deferring and delaying and
awkwardness show the mark of a
professional yes
yes absolutely that's absolutely when is
a writer show me a writer who says she's
satisfied with what she did and it went
well I'll show you an amateur so in the
beginning it's like a dating
it's a honeymoon phase everybody looks
perfect well the dating is better I mean
the stating works out you eventually you
get on well with with that person but
you never get on well with writing that
never changes again maybe God willing
you are able to make money at it and
actually support yourself at it but it's
always always painful always a struggle
and again it's about feeling that's what
it's about so it sort of makes sense
that it that it should be feeling full
when does a writer know it's time to
abandon a character you never really
know and I'm asked that all the time
about I'm asked two kinds of questions
like that what I call the macro version
and the micro version the micro version
it should I you've read this script
you've read several versions of it am i
beating a dead horse here should I just
move on I sure don't know I've seen
people rewrite scripts into oblivion
where they that should have gotten rid
of in my view and I've also seen
conversely scripts that look pretty
hopeless that suddenly broke through who
- say I can't tell you that it's a easy
for me to say but you've got it you've
got to do all the work on that that's
the micro version should I stick with
this script or should I give it up I'll
also say what is very useful is is to
put a script aside and write something
else and then come back to it and and
you'll have a new perspective on it the
macro version of that is and I get this
all the time should I do I have what it
takes to be a writer
am I good enough at this and my answer
is I don't know that's a
for me to say that's for you know should
I continue to do this actually I use my
answer that usually is no don't continue
to do this why not because you had to
ask me whether or not you should do it
if you need to ask somebody about
whether or not you should be righter
than you should not be a writer you
should be a writer because you can't
help yourself there's nothing else you
can do you just can't stop yourself you
got it you have to write not because
it's fun but because you have to do just
like you have to breathe you know
the we're as I said we are in the midst
of our admissions process here at UCLA
the take rate that is to say the number
of people who are admitted to our
program who actually enter the program
is very high and it's almost 90 percent
that almost hundred percent that's over
90 percent that is to say anybody who
gets admitted the program comes into the
program for the most part it's extremely
unusual that somebody's admitted to the
program and then has doubts about
whether or not they want to enter the
program and yet I met with somebody the
other day who had been admitted to the
program and now told me that he was
wondering whether or not he really will
enter the program and he wanted to ask
me some question about that you know and
I said to him look like you're asking me
should you into this program well he was
the way he put it was is this like a
reasonable intelligent thing to do and I
told him no no is it reasonable and
intelligent to think that you can create
characters and stories and make up
dialogue that they speak and that people
will line up in bad weather to pay over
14 or 16 dollars you know for a ticket
whatever request to go to the movies
these days to sit in a movie theater and
and you know watch this this thing that
you created
I mean imagine a
somebody stops you in the stream and
says I gotta tell you about this dream
that I had I had this dream I this dream
I gotta tell you about it so let's say
you were generous and a humane person
you say well okay let's hear it and
imagine that the person I mean you've
had the experience where you've wanted
to tell a dream that you had to somebody
and there are people who've surely said
to you oh I had to crazy you got to the
stream ahead what about just before they
tell you the dream they say oh before I
do this I you have to meet two
conditions one is you got to be ready to
sit there for two hours it's going to
give me two hours to tell you this dream
and the other thing is I mean that that
would stop me right there but that's not
the end of it it's just the beginning at
the end of it is I also want 15 dollars
or whatever a ticket cause I mean it's
crazy and I said to this person no don't
do it if you are wondering about it if
you have to ask about it then you
shouldn't you shouldn't do it I'm not
about to say to somebody
Oh give us a chance please you know
please be a writer and boy that's
nothing in it for the writer for me to
tell her that yeah and the same thing
with as I say on a narrower basis on
whether or not they going to write a
story you know whether or not this is
something that somebody should really
write about I was at a I go to a lot of
writers conferences I am an academic but
I don't go to too many scholarly
conferences but I do go to bunches of
writers conferences and I was at one
recently in Northern California and
there were a lot of agents there on
panels and so on and I was chatting with
them I was a presenter as they were and
I remember them complaining to me the
agents that writers are coming up to
them at the conference and saying what
should I write about what's hot now what
are you looking for imagine asking
somebody else what to write about I mean
if you don't have if the writer doesn't
care about what she's writing about why
would the agent care why would the
producer care why would audiences care
so again you have to you really really
can't look to anybody else other than is
itself in this enterprise
you